some of the guys that were in prison
Brazil all from the UK they just did a
show with me in the UK and they talked
about exactly how dangerous the jails
were there and how they survived through
me in those prisons the prisons in
Brazil yes and I was in three different
penitentiary in Brazil three different
prisons in Brazil yeah what was that
like like can you give me just one oh
yeah yeah I get specific story about a
Brazil prison experience so you know
when guys say to them you know you watch
movies at concentration camps yeah you
watch movies in the army and it's no
different than that we were in a
Brazilian penitentiary and when they
come crashing through those doors during
the riots and they come in with ski
masks and I'm talking about military
please please the SWAT teams in those
countries they all stripped us down
we're all naked gunstar heads you know
you beat up a little bit yeah
pistol-whipped a little bit dependent a
feel the wrong inmate and the wrong cop
but guys are getting beat up all over
the guys that get raped within the
jail's from the from the gods and were
brought into a some occasions were
brought into a dock like gymnasium but
there's no lights and it's probably a
hundred and twenty degrees in there 115
degrees and some of these guys that were
with me in the UK awesome start to come
out and speaking because they didn't
like what the county tried to project
about the prisons that we were in and he
tried to underplay how many killings
were in these jails and I'm talking
about dozens of them why would he try to
do that I don't know I I guess you're
gonna have to ask him that if he ever
doing it the view what anybody and you
know these things like we're doing here
they're not you you know this obviously
you can ask any question you want
I don't prearranged him right I talk
just from the heart I talk about
experience yeah he's not able to do that
because he lied so often and right and
talked out of school and he doesn't
realize this guy's all over the world
that were in those prisons with us that
we all stay in touch with each other we
just had a reunion you're the guys like
the you were like the feet on the ground
guys you guys are in the trenches
together you know you got guys from
Turkey to with the Spain that were with
this Denmark that was with us a couple
Italian guys from Italy don't with us so
when someone talks like he does and he
tries to [ __ ] at the public a little
bit
these guys just came out of the woodwork
and we're looking to do some shows now
on the Brazilian Penance entries that we
were in some of the riots some of the
things that I just spoke about the rapes
and inmate being hung and accused of
committing a crime he didn't get he
didn't commit
mmm so not to go you can if you need
answer you know I don't okay so you have
guys coming out of woodwork and they
weren't happy with some of the things
that was said and they want to set the
record straight at the same time they
start to do podcast shows about their
experience in these prisons how they
survived them and how they credited meat
for some of the violence I committed and
those presents to save them and some of
the stabbings I did and some of the
killings they witnessed some of the
rapes they witnessed and the conditions
of rats all over the the size and poison
and mosquitoes like crazy some of the
people they seemed I because we're so
below in a in a cage that was like I
guess like the old days torture chamber
is almost over the castles you see in
the movies
you really can't understand because
these two these prisons like state
senator from Brazil said he wouldn't
want to spend the day there rather die
first so these are document well
documented the the the torture was well
documented and the murders after it from
prisons half the guys were getting
killed and tortured they were sending
guys out from the street to kill those
same gods that were torture and rape and
really the gods and the police officers
started wearing masks black ski masks so
people know their face but some of the
the organizations in Brazil they were
very violent on the street yeah started
ringing at doorbells when they answered
him they were shoot em and I had to try
to get even for what they were doing in
a prison system I mean this is all
seeing and documented stuff and I was in
some of the prisons they talked about
and some of the guys that we meet with
with discussing obviously a TV series
about it and these guys from these
countries saw some of the things
obviously were involved in what I was
involved in and I got off course when we
were in those rooms
it was probably 500 guy
600 guys in a caged-in room nowhere to
[ __ ] nowhere to piss and would be we all
of us as selectively would select one
place in the corner no toilet paper no
shirts because when naked yeah and we
were brought in there like I said like a
concentration camp and we you know
you're stepping in walking on piss and
[ __ ] but we try to limit it to one
corner because we're there from some
mornings when they do these these
attacks on the inmates were there from
6:00 in the morning say till 10:00 at
night there's nowhere to sit no where
you're standing and your suffering and
guys are passing out and guys you know
some guys and some occasions were dying
from the inequality couldn't breathe and
I mean these are no secrets to the
International world of what went on in
somebody's jails or you're in and it's
no secret because was documented them TV
shows what CNN and news a Associated
Press yes the world and some of these
guys got in touch with me thank you
really
I gotta say thank you to God II for that
because they didn't know how to get in
touch with me and when we were in the
media they seen it they reached out and
got ahold of someone got ahold of my
daughter and said we need to speak to
your father he saved our life really in
prison and she said to me dad do you
know who Justin is and you know who
always and she started giving me names
and I said yeah why and she said I
didn't know if it was real or not they
reached out to me on Facebook and said
your dad saved our life and we want to
talk to him so this is some of some of
the guys and we're very you know we we
never forget each other because we went
through hell with each other and we had
a certain bond and that one of our
reunions was just last weekend in the UK
and we discussed with us a guide was
played Captain America actually in the
UK for Brit Co Santini and we talked to
him about maybe get involved in a
project with us and and my life story
and some of the things that were
thinking about doing so you know added
things are bad sometimes things a lot of
positive a lot of positive and you got
to make it positive that and really
that's the bottom line I really don't
care for Gotti too much is because he's
guided once a sitting [ __ ] right
doesn't want to turn things around that
do something positive and if he started
talking well and talking to children and
talking to kids about not being in a
life maybe or not being in the street
you can sell your own [ __ ] store
well you want I mean we can't change who
we were and what we did that's not gonna
change
obviously so we got to live with that
but let's sell something different to
the kids now no kids that are suffering
or you know there's kids that I know
real tough Street kids that talk to me
send me messages they're involved in the
street and I try to talk them out of
street hey let's party right you know
what because maybe they're not ready
some of them all I mean I got I get
dozens of letters out of prisons all the
time guys you know you know commending
me for what I do and this guy's that in
prisons that are never gonna change but
say you know tell me keep doing your
thing so you know there's a lot of
positive guys out there in the prison
system then believe in what I'm doing
and I guess the negative people always
gonna be negative I can't change that
it's a different breed of person someone
who has kind of been handed everything
they have they never really had to
suffer for it or really work for it you
know it's just the something that you
can't really teach it's they're just
different yet I mean there's a different
breed when you've had to go through hell
and you've had to earn everything that
you have there's a disconnect there
between someone else who's just been
given everything no I'm not saying that
you guys are he's that or you're how
would you say understand it's listen I
could tell you this at my age and
growing up in jails the way I was a
young kid the first time I went I met
some tough tough guys in prison so when
guys think they're tough out in the
street you could think it's awful you
want when you get into all these prisons
there's so many tough guys in there
there's so many dangerous guys and
there's so many killers in there you
know there's you're nothing in there
just like anybody else you're just
another number you're another guy trying
to get through today and you the reality
of the real tough guys in prison
the real street guys in prison the guys
that say to themselves I don't want to
see my kid have to spend a day here
because we understand what it is so the
guys that say anything different than
that you let
know who he is when you see some jackoff
and the Internet and they're right and
some dumb [ __ ] about the code I would
tell that [ __ ] guide is right about
the code first of you never loved you
live you never lived a code you'd have
no idea what all life's about they're
definitely gonna be comments on that
dummies it you can't stop people that
hate their lives I just want to well
they want 10 seconds of attention yeah
so you give it to them but if they want
that attention like that Oh go join jump
in get to jail all right we're gonna see
how tough you and see if you talk they
don't have the nuts to do that but what
I was getting at is these inmates that
are in jail and there's thousands and
thousands right across the country every
country you're not gonna find one that's
gonna send a message out different that
to their own children they don't want
their kids live in his life so you know
if we could all talk to kids and guys in
and I'm talking about inmates that
aren't death row inmates that are in
Supermax jails any if you ask any of
them there's none of them are gonna say
oh this is a great life I want my kid in
the street pray so you know we did what
we did they did what they did
I'm in a position whether somebody likes
me or dislikes me I can't change that
and when someone says well this guy
hurts so many guys all he's full of [ __ ]
he didn't hurt that many I really don't
give a [ __ ] you know so these are guys
that have you know [ __ ] [ __ ] guys
that talk like this and yeah you know
they're not tough guys they're not men
and when they're talking like this woman
it's all that same big mouth that says
something different or the code go put
your [ __ ] kid on the street all right
if that's what you believe tough guy go
put it but I'm gonna tell you something
else any of the real tough guys cuz
there's a lot on the street and in jail
they're not gonna be writing on your
computer about it and they show hell no
this is just jerk-offs they talk like
that yeah Esther that's true yeah that's
fact
um now you said how much time did you in
solitary I probably did I never count
the day for day but I've done probably
about seven years and in solitary
confine I didn't see y'all not not
continuous that was just told I was in
and out of them but but I'll tell you
what I was in Brazil Penitentiary for
two and a half years and it seen a yard
once a month naked in my underwear at
best no shoes not on rocks and it's not
a yard like you see a yard I'm not
talking about a yard
talking about a high-security gun
patrols there up in the towers dogs all
over you and it's I guess the size of a
basketball court at best I got that once
a month otherwise I was caged in I never
left the cells I was in cells with 54
guys that fit 12 guys sometimes higher
than not in the 60s
it rained inside the cells they had
water that went up to our knees at
points darkness storms there was
blackouts complete no lights so you know
that was the conditions when I came to
Florida I was out on the tiers for a
while but you're on tears that you don't
go out to yah does that mean other cage
tears tears or double level tears in
Florida prisons and you don't really
leave that that pod then I wanted to
solitary cells for a couple years and
then I was in MCC forced into a unit
where there's nine cells on the floor
and you're not leaving those cells and
you're stuck there 23 for 24 hours you
go up on a basketball court at night for
about an hour three days a week so I
never seen an actual yard so that was
ten years of that prior to that I was in
and out of solitary confinement for
fights six months at a time eight months
I was I did about a year straight at
another time so yeah I spent my fair
share of time in solitary confinement
and listen I'm no different because you
hear guys complaining about it but when
your high profile inmate which I was I
was chased down by Interpol in every
country and when you're killing guys and
hurting guys I'm no different than a lot
of these guys we're all going to the
same thing so what I'm saying is it's
not a life to live like a dog in a cage
right and the showering and with a
camera watching you and you know you're
on the secure cells so there's cameras
in the room you take a [ __ ] they're
watching you yeah you feel horny that
day and you want to jerk off they're
watching you so this is the life that
you chose to lead so when a guy talks
out of school and you're gonna get
dummies that talk like that all the time
they have no idea about how I lived in a
lot of inmates just like me
[Music]
[Laughter]